willkommen zurück bei bild live an
diesem sonntagmorgen an dem uns wieder
dramatische bilder aus der ukraine
erreicht haben wir sehen zb heftige
explosionen in grammatik das ist in der
ost ukraine nördlich von donezk und
charkiw wird weiter schwer getroffen man
sieht abgeschossene wracks zb von einem
kampfjet bei nikolajew das ist dann
südlich der ukraine der pilot soll
überlebt haben die bilder sehe gleiche
sehen wir jetzt noch einen parkplatz und
ein brennendes wohngebäude
tatsächlich wirklich dramatische bilder
die uns da aus der nacht erreicht haben
hier sehen wir jetzt den abgeschossenen
kampfjet auf einem feld wir sehen davor
auch noch jemanden der das filmt einen
soldaten ob das sich tatsächlich nun um
einen kampfjet handelt ist unklar es gab
auch wieder bombeneinschläge in das ist
ein vorort von kiew sehen wir hier
mitten in einem wohngebiet man sieht ja
sogar noch den brennenden krater ja und
auch dort wurden bürogebäude zivile
gebäude getroffen die zerstörung ist
wirklich gewaltig muss man sagen wenn
man hier so durchgeht da steht kaum noch
ein stein auf dem anderen und hier sehen
wir eben das angesprochene bürogebäude
was auch heftig getroffen wurde die
zerstörungen sind wirklich dramatisch
wir sehen hier noch die rauchschwaden
die da rauskommen und jetzt sehen wir
tatsächlich auch noch live dann wie die
reifen da
einschießen und jetzt sehen wir einen
konvoi tatsächlich einen russischen
konvoi der verlassen wurde das ist in
der nähe von haag it firmen auf diese
bilder gehen wir dann gleich nochmal
gesondert ein
putins armee die wird offenbar immer
ihren loser denn die soldaten die
schießen jetzt offenbar schon gezielt
auf unbewaffnete demonstranten
in der ukrainischen siedlung nobs corp
das ist eine nähe von lohans in der ost
ukraine der wurde gestern erst friedlich
gegen die russischen besatzer
demonstriert bis dann das hier passierte
putins killerkommando richtete die
waffen auf die demonstranten und
schossen und ein mann wurde dabei auch
wer verletzt